between you know the lego movie and a
sequel to the lego movie a 22 Jump
Street reboot another spider-man movie I
think you guys are involved in a lot of
projects that maybe on the surface don't
look like they should work
yes but they end up dude working and I'm
one word actually it's going to be on
our tombs yeah exactly
I'm what the key is for that for you
guys but just finding little love things
and making them very very well I don't
know why we choose these things I think
we want to do something that seems like
it's hiding in plain sight maybe I know
that once we picked them because we find
something inspiring about that in the
Jump Street movies it was this romance
between two men who don't realize
they're in love and with the Lego movies
it's wow there's this thing it's like a
tool for creativity and people use it
all around the world to tell stories and
and could we make a movie that was about
that right you know the first thing you
think it was like oh that's a cynical
cash grab of a movie and that's why we
said no the first time making the first
lego movie and then we starts thinking
about like well you know what it's like
clay you know people make these
stop-motion films with Lego and it's
really just a medium for creativity and
if we treat it like that then you can
really tell a cool story with it we
started getting excited about it and
that's how it happens every time the
crack was for you guys storyteller well
we always had this idea that you know
the first movie it was Finn the human
boy imagination that we were seeing in
the Lego universe and then he started
painting ourselves in the corner at the
end of it and then we thought well we're
not being interesting to tell a movie
from two different imaginations point of
view so half of the movie is from an
older version of Finn's point of view
that's into sci-fi and more grown-up
storytelling and then another half is
from his eight-year-old sisters point of
view and who's in two totally different
things and have those two point of views
collide
and have you tried to figure out which
he's telling what story and having them
come together the hard part is making
them both work I'm making a make you can
watch this movie twice and you should in
the theater and watch it from Finn's
sister's point of view and it all makes
sense and you can watch it all the way
from Finn's point of view it all makes
sense and so that was certainly the
hardest thing to get to make sense and
to make it work as a story and be
satisfying so that's why it took us five
years to get this debate oh here it is
here it is and one of the biggest fun
fun parts of both of these movies all
the you know the cameos or mother IP and
all that all the Easter eggs in the
background I wonder if there's anything
you're particularly proud of made it
into into this oh gosh Ruth Bader
Ginsburg my childhood hero Gary Payton
is an older childhood bya my childhood
hero Sheryl Swoopes there you go adult
childhood and adult heroes Bruce Willis
Bruce Willis yeah that's a good one and
that was revised gang there's a whole
there's so many things in the movie the
hero and the guy obviously styled myself
after Jason Ebola right goes without
saying you know see me you're like that
guy's mo mo where you yourself stop
walking around looking like Jace we'll
put your name on this interview so
people don't get I know it's very
important
[Music]